Hãy hai năm 2020, các phát biểu của tổng thống Mỹ đường nân Trump, liên quan đến chương trình
tên lừa và hạp nhân của nước này trong thông diệu lưỡi bằng trước của họ Mỹ,
người phân ngôn bộ ngoài sau Yvang S. May, 8G, cho sang, các cáu buộc vytên lừa đàn đạo
suy lộn đẹp, chương trình hạp nhân và sống thương vang trong các cuộc bất đồng gần đây là không đúng với sự thật.
Chứ đỏ trong thông diệu lưỡi bằng hàng in không tra mi sấu, tổng thống đường nân Trump cáu buộc,
tây ra đăng phát tri tế lừa có thể sống vương tởi lãnh thống Mỹ, đồng thời khẳng đệ,
Washington sẽ không cho phép Yvang sử vô vô kiểm nhận và xem các trình trình buôn sử của nước này là mối đây soạn đối với khu bật.
Nếu nhận công đang thuy tục ra tăng hiện dễ quân sử tại trung đông, trong mỗi kèng các thẳng ngày một lau thang,
theo các đánh giá thình bảo Mỹ, Yvang có thể phát tri tế lộ đàn đạo suy lộn đẹp trong tương ai,
nếu theo đổi năng lượng ngày, sống chưa có cái loạn về quy định chính thức,
về phần mình, tay ra nguồn khẳng đệnh chư trình hạp nhân phục vụ bộ bộ bi sinh sử,
đồng thời cho biết sẵn sàng đàn phát lưỡng ngoại sào đủ tiền, nhưng cũng cạnh báo sẽ đáp trả nếu bị cân công.